les rencontres de la rochelle sont
mortes vive le festival c'est en effet
un festival nouvelle formule qui a été
mis sur pied cette année l'équipe
d'organisation et la même qu'auparavant
mais le directeur a changé alain durel
le nouveau directeur et son équipe ont
connu quelques difficultés
d'organisation et grâce à l'aide de
partenaires locaux et régionaux et aussi
grâce à la municipalité de la rochelle
le festival a pu être mis sur pied et
présente un programme aussi diversifiée
qu'intéressant c'est un festival de
plusieurs disciplines comme on dit c'est
à dire musique théâtre danse arts
plastiques cinéma et avec plusieurs
périodes dans ce festival notamment nous
démarrons avec la musique
ensuite il y aura le cinéma et il y aura
aussi le théâtre et la danse qui
termineront mais les périodes ne sont
pas aussi séparés c'est à dire que il y
a des jours où l'on trouve les trois
activités ou les quatre activités à la
fois ils seront les moments forts de ce
festival les moments forts sont
finalement le tous les moments de
création où les moments de projections
de films inédits et je crois qu'on peut
dire entre aujourd'hui entre le 25 juin
et le 14 juillet on va essayer d'avoir
des moments fort pratiquement chaque
jour c'est la musique qui va ouvrir ce
festival la musique contemporaine
constitue un champ privilégié
d'expérimentation le public rochelais
risquent d'être surpris
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas ici dans une salle de
jeu mais dans une salle de concert les
musiciens ne se présentera de se
détendre
ils répètent sous la direction de leur
chef d'orchestre
[Musique]
où
la verrière la la la
14 heures
on s'est dit que le bruit urbain le plus
futile
c'était évidemment celui du flipper donc
à partir de là on pouvait essayer de
créer une musique entre kim et
naturellement et c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est une première mondiale pour écouter
j'en sais rien je suis pas allé voir ce
qu'ils font à tokyo peut-être qu'il ya
quelqu'un qu'il fait en ce moment en
tout cas en france c'est sûrement la
première fois comment vous avez recruté
vos musiciens des gens d'ici au talent
il joue bien ce sont des bons musiciens
flipper et vous même vous êtes un joueur
de plus peur ah non moi je suis un
auditeur de flipper je suis totalement
nul est inhibée par ces appareils là je
ne sais pas jouer au flipper
[Musique]
ambiance
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]